Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein mega einfaches Dessert,
was ich früher als Kind immer ganz gerne gemacht hab mit meiner Schwester.
Wir machen ein Dessert, das ist so ein bisschen 'ne Pudding-Creme,
also wir kochen jetzt gleich einen Pudding.
Und dann kommt Zwieback zum Einsatz, das haben wir früher immer gemacht!
Später schließen wir noch ab mit 'ner Schokoladensoße.
Sehr simpel aber dennoch sehr lecker und von jedem immer wieder gemocht!
Und ich mach jetzt hier so ne Art Milchpudding.
Ich hab jetzt hier Milch in meinem Topf und der Herd ist noch nicht an.
Ich geb jetzt zuallererst Mehl für die Bindung mit rein.
Dann natürlich Zucker für die Süße und ganz wichtig: Vanilleextrakt.
Weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen sonst hat man ja nur, wirklich nur Milch, Zucker, Mehl.
Und Vanilleextrakt ist so dieses ausschlaggebende Aroma,
dieser ausschlaggebende Geschmack.
Damals haben wir Vanillezucker genommen, mittlerweile
gibt es das ja richtig schön konzentriert, ich verlink euch meins in die Infobox.
Und das wird jetzt klümpchenfrei verrührt. Also wirklich dass gar keine Mehlklumpen  mehr
vorhanden sind.
Und dann erst unter ständigem Rühren aufkochen lassen, also den Herd einschalten.
Unser Milchpudding dickt ein sobald es aufkocht und dann ist es ganz wichtig,
das Ganze einmal umzufüllen.
Und dann vollständig auskühlen lassen, am besten zugedeckt an der Oberfläche.
Das dauert auch so 1 1/2 - 2h, die Zeit müsst ihr euch einfach nehmen,
weil jetzt kommt steif geschlagene Schlagsahne mit dazu, das hab ich
hier schon erledigt.
Einfach unterrühren. Und wenn's jetzt noch warm wär, dann würde die Sahne schmelzen
und das wär nicht so gut!
Und danach geben wir auch schon Zwieback dazu, ich mach das immer noch
mit der Hand so ein bisschen klein.
Und anschließend wird's in eine Auflaufform gefüllt.
Auf die Zwieback-Pudding Schicht kommt jetzt noch 'ne Schokosoße.
Und dafür ganz einfach Sahne erhitzen, ganz vorsichtig, dass der Topfboden nicht anbrennt.
Dann Vollmilchschokolade reingeben und mit einander verschmelzen lassen.
Das Ganze lasst ihr 10min stehen, damit's leicht abkühlt
und gebt es dann auf die Puddingschicht.
Und danach könnt ihr dekorieren wie ihr möchtet,
ich hab jetzt Mandelkrokant genommen. Ich liebe Mandelkrokant!
Ihr könntet auch Kokosnuss nehmen, also Kokosraspeln oder z.B. Pistazien.
Oder ihr lasst es pur, ganz wie ihr möchtet.
Wichtig ist, dass das Ganze jetzt nochmal zum Kühlen für 3 Stündchen in den Kühlschrank kommt.
Dann ändert sich auch nochmal so ein bisschen was an der Konsistenz und ihr werdet merken,
dass das alles so ein bisschen leicht fest und cremiger wird.
Und dann könnt ihr's einfach nur genießen!
Und das ist so ein Rezept, das mach ich gerne wenn z.B. Schwiegerfamilie kommt
oder meine Familie oder alle zusammen!
Da guckt mal, da können ganz viele von essen!
(H: Und so günstig eigentlich, ne?)
Und es ist günstig!
Nein es ist ja wirklich so, wir haben ja auch wenig Zutaten hier gebraucht heute
und es können echt mega viele von essen.
Und wir beide freuen uns dann morgen drauf, dass wir das verspeisen.
(H: Also nicht jetzt:( )
Nicht jetzt, weil wie gesagt 3h lang kühlen!
Es sei denn, du willst um 0 Uhr nachts noch einen Kuchen essen, dann..
(H: Ja, ist kein Problem!)
Dann können wir das auch machen!
Euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen!
Schreibt auf jeden Fall in die Kommentare, wie's euch gefallen hat
wenn ihr's dann nachgemacht habt.
Nicht vergessen: bei mir immer in der Videobeschreibung schauen, da stehen
die ganz genauen Mengenangaben und alles, was ich im Video so verwendet hab.
Und dann freu ich mich, wenn ihr meinem Video ein Däumchen nach oben da lasst
und mich kostenlos abonniert, dann verpasst ihr solch geniale Rezepte auch nicht mehr!
Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept wieder!
Ciao ciao, eure Kiki!
(H: Ciao Ciao!)
Tschüüss!
(H: Tschü tschü!)
(K: Und?)
Schmeckt einfach!
(K: Schmeckt so locker-leicht, ne?)
Locker-leicht, ja!
(K: Kann man mal machen, ne?)
-Das sind diese Rezepte, wenn man irgendwie Besuch hat
und so ein riesen Buffet hat und so mehrere verschiedene Kuchen hat
(K: Ja dann ist das so ein typisches Dessert!)
Dann ist das so ein typisches einfaches Dessert, ne?
Es ist einfach und schnell!
(K: Einfach und schnell!)
(K: Und wann kommt's online? Demnächst! Wie gesagt, wir haben wirklich geile Rezepte für euch vorgedreht!)